Oh Charlie yeah again
no good
and
did you talk to your family yeah
your kids
you're accessing yeah
okay
[Music]
all right so TJ yeah did you where
you're from Rita from Ohio
small town do you want to have three
years what brought your death here um
well the guy I was with
we caught a case in Ohio and he got out
and came down here so I followed him
plus the drugs are easy here so that is
possession um yeah and where do you
sleep
where yeah usually like 10:00 to 10:00 I
had one but you yeah I'm try not to look
like the people with you go yeah it's
easy not to look like that
yeah it's you is I go get up in take a
shower yeah
Jennifer Charlie um okay so
pretty much like growing up like it was
just me for a little bit my mom got
pregnant my brother and my stepdad was
the biggest coke dealer in their small
town so we had everything we wanted but
the cops were robbing us right in our
place like they throw in like the flash
bombs and like everything to be all
bright we could associate even stepdad
my dad his dad was on the floor arrest
didn't [ __ ] and then we went to that for
like six years and my home is a big
alcoholic so you know she used to beat
me all the time
pretty much I saw her as my brother
because she quit being attention eyes
you said you were raising my brother
yeah so my mom three different guys I
like any now some of them like a couple
of times like you know they kind of like
started they'd hit on me my shot at
getting older and thank you
coke like one time I woke up and like
when I was boy friends was like in the
bed with me and [ __ ] that was weird
probably like 13
yeah and then my mom got back with my
stepdad after he got out of prison
hey it started getting weird then too
like I caught him filming me when I was
taking a shower she like that
and not [ __ ] me up because that
supposed to be like my dad you know my
real dad was in Pennsylvania like he's
cool and all but like I don't know what
I'm talk to him my mom just died two
years ago
she'll deal on heroin but she didn't do
heroin so it wasn't her boyfriend got
you on Terry manslaughter my brother's
like 19 now I don't really know like my
childhood was just [ __ ] up you know
that my house was a party house
everybody any other party y'all you know
I mean like growing up you know I mean
like there's cleanup needles and I had
beer bottles
[ __ ] you know I mean so long here I just
turned 25 in April I don't know what are
you everybody
oh you know see you guys for that yeah
cuz the days I'm slow yeah I mean
there's but when I first got here like
you know I look - I look better now the
way I did because I was strung out but I
had guys drive-ins me offered me five
dollars
like you know the [ __ ] [ __ ] and I was
like yeah sure okay get in the car take
two five hundred to get out like [ __ ] I
got this place is really cheap words
like to see yourself in five years I
always wanted to be like you know like a
mom like I say Oh mom but like a good
mom I was gonna be better than my mom
you know I mean yeah
I don't see myself here yeah well you're
still young beautiful you can make that
happen
I mean if I don't end up doing that I'm
probably dead because you know they'll
look around it's a bit of moving there
yeah but some when you look around and
they look older but they're really not
yeah yeah that's okay yeah you hang out
there like eventually yeah yeah because
sometimes like I can't get up cuz like
my back's hurt my knees were and she
like that I never
I mean we don't for like seven years
those bad down here
they be holding my skin is it weird but
because the heroin that makes your skin
yeah
yes here you know they got fentanyl and
that's my mom my brother died off of my
big brother is there kind of hell on the
heroin you good yeah cuz I if any it's
everywhere like candy we get a batch of
hair without fun all right
yeah they got test strips down at the
needle exchange you put it in the cooker
when you're done cooking up you should
stick it in there and tell you how much
retinol in it yeah pretty much
[Music]
whoo what else is a like
I don't want to say we like it it's
gotta be okay I'm going to say well like
I've got a problem with like I'd bounce
back and forth from like different parts
of my life like cuz stuff just comes up
always this happened in a happening
because that's what really happened was
like you don't say but I don't make
sense because it would be like I go from
like 12 to like 18 to like you know 15
years old and they I mean I guess it's
just my udg but they I think probably
living in the projects was the hardest
when I was growing up because my mom was
bad on my bad drinking their drinking in
that's when I like all the guys would
come over and [ __ ] like that it's
something I'll starting first coming
over so my mom would I think I'd have to
get my brother for school I'd miss my
bus usually my mom broke up three of my
ribs one time like kicking me because I
missed my bus one time so she had to get
up and take me where her to school
that's when Children Services started
coming in but like I'd always like clean
the house up real quick you know I mean
so we wouldn't get taken away but I
ended up getting taken away anyways
because I was a bad kid I guess
and I got put in 21 different foster
homes I was in and out of juvie 14 yeah
my brother got to stay with his dad
I got put do this just don't
even in jail yeah oh yeah oh I can't
even tell you too many
what's the hardest part about the
hores barn
probably the [ __ ] there you go
through the men probably like because
everybody wants
if you're white and you're cute
everybody wants a part of you I got
three we need a piece of you make
everybody wants to TJ TJ hey over here
it doesn't matter how many times I've
seen him one day doesn't matter
I've been into how their tent for two
hours you know I mean they're still
yelling my name it's like looking just
the inner tent like it's creepy you had
some crazy stuff that guy's big yeah
yeah
[Music]
twice one time this guy his maxim picked
me up in his truck and he choked me out
and you don't mean he raped me or
whatever but like the crazy part was was
he can't pass around the tent every day
and just wave at me
me and my dude my dude I didn't tell my
dude who he was because you know I don't
know why I didn't tell him but I told
him afterwards after we moved somewhere
else but that was [ __ ] up cuz he kept
I'd see him everyday afterwards you mean
because he makes sure I'd see him
the hardest day of my intrepid me was
when I got kidnapped in Ohio because I
was fighting with my my boyfriend at the
time but I got it was an alcohol date I
don't usually do alcohols which beat
which means you go you need your spot to
go to their spot but I dig says man and
my boyfriend and I was texting my cousin
getting in the car everything like that
so I wasn't pay attention to the guy
driving and when we started going out
the parking lot my boy Freddie man
crossed past us it was like what are you
doing it where you going I was like you
know [ __ ] whatever whoa like an hour
away the dude was like oh by the way we
can't go to my house and you are my
roommates there and start taking meeting
woods so that is my boy I was like okay
something's going on I'm going in the
woods now and started calling and dude
grabbed my cellphone somebody's
windshield it's very fun you hear that
all day long
so anyways my trying to buy the car you
don't have me punch me and drag me back
on the car and you know he did whatever
you know he did whatever then driving up
the RVs and texted me said I hope you
learn from our talk again
[Music]
somebody paid for a taxi from Philly
from Lima to Finley which is like an
hour and 45 minutes away so I can get
back home that was the end of that but
that's really the hardest only because
like I knew my boyfriend I thought I was
gonna die I'm smiling because I don't
know what else to do but yeah it doesn't
it that that's the only time I really
thought I was gonna die there's been a
couple times when I've been like close
to death but like there's some about me
were like I'd always get out of like
stuff I don't know what it airboats are
you give him something situations yeah
yeah I wanna say that's right thank you
very much for talking me okay yeah yeah